so so far this year we have had
wonderful lectures on a wide range of
topics including the intersections
between civilizations its circa 1030 in
fluence the literature of World War one
and how human social networks support us
all in interesting ways we didn't know
about so now we're going today we're
turning our focus away from planet earth
to beyond our planet and its history out
toward the universe and emerging
knowledge about its dark side as we're
going to hear Priya natarajan is a
professor in the Department of astronomy
and physics here at Yale she's a
theoretical astrophysicist interested in
cosmology gravitational lensing and
black hole physics I'm hoping we all
understand what those words mean shortly
she is particularly interested in making
Dark Matter maps of clusters of gallery
galaxies the largest known repositories
of dark matter Priya was an under has
undergraduate degrees in physics and
math from MIT and did her graduate work
in theoretical astrophysics at the
University of Cambridge she was awarded
a guggenheim fellowship for to work at
university of colorado and thus
harvard-smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics as well as giving many many
other lectures in a wide variety of
places in addition to her research and
teaching Priya also works extensively
toward building gender equity in the
Academy and especially in the sciences
and here at Yale that was through her
work as a past chair of the women's
faculty forum and ongoing work with the
WFF and as a board a member of the board
of the edge certified foundation so
Priya would be very happy if you want
wish to interrupt her with questions
during her talk and I've asked her to
leave some time at the end for more
questions and I'll just remind you that
there is a reception in the MacDougal
common room right afterward so you can
and we usually have food
by the lecture so I'm kind of curious
what kind of outer space food we're
going to have today so please join me in
welcoming Priya today for a lecture okay
thank you very much thanks for that very
kind introduction and it's a real
pleasure and a privilege to be able to
talk to all of you here it's one of my
first public talks at Yale have been
here for more than 10 years the longest
that I've actually lived in any city in
my entire life anyway what I want to
talk to you today about our aspects of
the universe that particularly interests
me and one of the goals of my talk is to
of course show you why these aspects
invisible and mysterious as they are are
so exciting and how we can yet to learn
a lot more than one originally imagines
one can given that the structures that
we are talking about or dark matter the
entities are dark matter and dark energy
that don't really interact with any
known substance so the essential is
invisible to the eyes says the Fox in
the little prince it's one of my
favorite stories and the human
imagination has always been fascinated
with the invisible and the unseen so
we've started in physics or in early
science with ether with my asthma which
is this fluid that was supposed to cause
disease phlogiston which is supposed to
give substances the ability to burn
prior to the discovery of oxygen so
these were all shown to be non-existent
in the end with empirical science right
and I'm just telling you that we have
these mysterious entities whose nature
we don't actually know we know they
exist and that's part of what I want to
do today to persuade you about how dark
matter and dark energy are actually
different from phlogiston why should you
believe in dark matter in fact more than
ever
we have to believe in these very
invisible forces because we have
incontrovertible data and i'm going to
show you what the data is and how the
quality of that data has vastly improved
in the last 15 to 20 years so it turns
out that the major constituents of our
universe are these two mysterious
components dark matter and dark energy
most of the matter more than ninety
percent of the actual matter in our
universe is dark matter and this is
stuff that is not on the periodic table
so these are not ordinary atoms and we
believe that these were likely particles
that were generated very early in the
universe and there are some candidates
for what these particles might be they
are as yet undetected so let me as you
can imagine the I've been working in
this field since my PhD in the early
2000s and it takes a lot of people it
really does take a village to carry out
one's research agenda in science mine is
a small village compared to many other
groups I work in small collaborations so
I just wanted to acknowledge many
current and past students at Yale
postdocs and collaborators elsewhere and
also want to acknowledge the support
that I've gotten from NASA and SF
various foundations and also support
from Yale in particular i do want to
give a shout out to Yale
high-performance computing so what do we
know about the universe so I start out
with a few preliminaries and then launch
right into unveiling the dark side of
the universe for you so the composition
of the universe as we have now the
cosmic inventory that we currently have
is that dark energy constitutes about
seventy percent of the total energy
density of the universe and Dark Matter
twenty-five percent but ninety percent
of the overall matter content and we
have a small sliver about four percent
which is the free hydrogen and helium
that was synthesized in the first
three minutes right after the Big Bang
so right after during the Big Bang and
after when the universe was very hot and
dense but then started expanding right
after the universe cool down so rapidly
that no elements beyond lithium-7 could
be synthesized in the early universe so
we had to wait for the formations of the
first stars to synthesize all the other
heavy elements that you see here which
actually constitute a really piddly
amount point zero three percent so all
the stuff that were made of everything
came well after the free hydrogen and
helium that was generated in the very
early universe so this is where this is
very sort of our cosmic inventory stands
and you can see that the bulk of the
composition dark matter and dark energy
are unknown we don't know their nature
and you can imagine that probably
astrophysicists and you may be right in
thinking so have a tendency to attach
dark on to something that they don't
really understand it's actually worked
very well so we feel like we have a
conception even though we don't quite
understand it so briefer than the cosmic
history animation that is shown to you
before Big Bang Theory for those of you
who watch that show with the little
nerds here is a brief graphic history of
the history of the universe so what you
see here is the start with inflation and
there were very small fluctuations in
the generated after inflation in the
density field as density field is in the
matter density which is primarily dark
matter and what is shown here as zoom
out are actually places and times in the
universe from which we actually have
data so we have data from when the
universe was 400,000 years so this these
are the photons radiation streaming to
us right after the Big Bang and that has
encountered everything else in the
universe that has assembled afterward so
we are seeing the imprint and these
photons this microwave background
radiation is detected all around us it's
uniform in the sky with very very small
fluctuations flutter
patience in one part in 10,000 or so and
those small fluctuations carry
information about every galaxy every
cluster of galaxies every blob of gas
they have encountered on their way to us
then of course with the biggest
telescopes that we have now and the
instrumentation and the various filters
various wavelengths beyond optical that
are currently available to us we are
able to see when the first stars and
galaxies assemble so we now have data so
these are epochs where we now have data
and then of course the present day when
the universe is 13.7 13.8 billion years
old we have a lot of data we have
copious amounts of data about galaxies
nearby and the dark matter that's
associated with galaxies and the dark
matter that seems to be smeared
everywhere in the universe so before I
move on to showing you what the
incontrovertible evidence is for dark
matter a couple of preliminaries so I
just want to focus on some properties of
light which are somewhat essential to
understand the arguments that I'm going
to make first first off when we look out
into the night sky with our telescopes
be be they on the ground or launched on
satellites we are looking back in time
so the deeper we look the father back we
can access in time and as time goes on
more and more of the universe becomes
accessible to us so that's what that
graphic shows you this doesn't mean that
we are the center of the universe there
is no Center to the universe this is
just a visualization to show you that
the observable region of the universe is
actually limited it's limited by the
finite speed of light and the finite age
of the universe so we can only so see so
far so a million years later more of the
universe will come into view so then the
other concept that is going to come in
handy for us is how do we actually
measure the speeds of stars in galaxies
that's going to be critical in terms of
the evidence for dark matter and the way
that is done is by looking at the
fingerprints of stars the stellar
spectrum or spectra and what you see
there in blue
red are basically identical spectra of a
galaxy the red one is of a galaxy that
is receding away from us and the blue
one is of a nearby galaxies and so what
you see you see the same features you
see the same absorption lines from
calcium magnesium and so on but they are
shifted so in the laboratory frame we
know where those lines appeared in terms
of wavelength and once we get photons
from distant galaxies we look at the
spectrum we look at the displacements of
those lines the broadening of those
lines we can infer the systematic
motions of stars within the galaxy as
well as the relative motion of that
galaxy with respect to us so that's the
key that's how we make measurements in
astronomy and these measurements of
distance and of velocity have been
critical to the discovery of dark matter
and making a convincing case for dark
matter but of course the most convincing
evidence for dark matter comes not from
the gravity of dark matter which you can
see affected in motions but from light
bending so i'll be talking a lot about
light bending and what is interesting
about light bending is as a
visualization here suppose the geometry
of our universe was the outside of a
sphere and as the universe expands the
wavelength of light actually stretches
as the universe expands on time ok and
that's sort of what is visualized here
so if we put these things together it's
very very fitting to talk about these
matters this year because it's the
Centennial for Einsteins publication of
his paper on the theory of general
relativity and what's the fuss about
general relativity and why do we all
worship Einstein so much what's this
hero worship about so it turns out that
it's an incredibly here and incredibly
profound insight ok and the insight was
that the Fate the geometry and the
contents of the universe are totally
interlinked so if we can do a cosmic
inventor
and if we can figure out whether our
universe is expanding contracting
accelerating decelerating then we can
figure out the geometry so knowledge of
any two of these constrains you so his
equations the equations of general
relativity coupled these and they
actually thankfully for us they actually
have only three solutions that are
reasonable so the game in observational
cosmology has been to figure out which
of those three solutions three unique
solutions corresponds to our universe
okay which track is our universe on but
before I do that let me just remind you
that you know in the inventory Dark
Matter does not emit any radiation in
any wavelength it does not interact with
anything so it's it doesn't emit in the
x-rays or the radio waves or the
microwaves and it just has gravity and
so it will affect motions motions of
stars and planets and motions in
galaxies and beyond just as Newton
revealed to us okay so F equals MA so
you have a gravitating mass it have a
gravitational force that falls off as
one over R squared and so that's the
that's the evidence for dark matter so
the evidence for dark matter that I will
first be showing you is from motions and
that's a completely new tonian view okay
you didn't need Einstein for that right
you didn't need n stein for that
interpretation but then the other piece
of evidence which i think is more
convincing that i'll show you needed
Einstein so Newton needed to be upended
for that view right but those two lines
of evidence but you know Newton being
upended doesn't mean that our intuition
about Newton's laws are wrong or they're
invalid they said they have a regime of
validity so on a on a on scales of
systems Newton's laws are perfectly
valid it's only when we want to put out
satellites and we want to have a GPS on
our phone then we need to take into
account Einstein's theory of general
relativity so there are regimes of
validity and what I'm going to show you
is evidence for dark matter in two
dingley in both limits both from Newton
and from Einstein although I principally
work on Einstein's constraints from
Einstein's equations okay so these are
those unique solutions those three
possibilities for our universe depending
on the contents and the geometry so what
is shown in the y-axis is the size scale
of the universe the physical size scale
and on the x-axis is time so what you
see is you have one solution all
solutions start off expand there's a
solution that contracts back that's a
universe that will contract back there
is one that will keep posting forever
and there's one that's perfectly
balanced just so and guess what that's
the one that our universe that that's
the track that our universe is on
however as we saw the ingredients that
keep that universe our universe just saw
on the gesso solution are extremely
peculiar they are dark matter and dark
energy okay so another really nice
visualization from one of my colleagues
at the Space Telescope Science Institute
it shows you here again those three
fates which if you don't like graphs you
can see in this beautiful picture that
these are the three different fates for
the three possible solutions and the
idea is this is time this is cosmic time
this is fast that's the future so this
is now and the question is we have one
universe in which we can make
observations so what can we observe now
that will allow us to discriminate
between these three models and it turns
out that what was observed and was
actually reported the discovery of dark
energy was the brightnesses of distant
supernovae these standard light bulbs
like your 60 watt watt light bulb whose
physics we pure understand very very
well when they go off in distant parts
of the universe we can measure how faint
they are and we know light falls off as
one over R squared it turns out that
these distant supernovae standard light
bulbs were not fainter than just
accounting than you would accounting for
the distance so that suggested the only
possibility was actually the universe
was not only expanding but the
acceleration which was accelerating the
expansion was accelerated
then the question is as you know from
your car if you have an acceleration
what's the gas pedal so it turns out
that gas pedal is dark energy that's
what's driving the accelerating
expansion of the universe and really
that's all we really know about it what
we do know about it is that we can
furama tries it in an interesting way
not necessarily a particularly
insightful way in terms of figuring out
what the origin is when did dark how did
it come to be when did it kick in etc
etc but we have a way of writing it as
an equation of state that kind of loves
a sort of a placeholder way of dealing
with it anyway let me move right along
to the dark component that interests me
more and that is dark matter so to
understand what's really going on in
terms of the dynamical evidence for dark
matter Alan Newton so let's train our
eyes back to the solar system so we have
the Sun here is the major gravitating
body in the solar system and you have
the planets lined up and you know I went
to school when Pluto was still a planet
so Pluto still there and so what we have
now is a plot of the speeds the orbital
speeds of the planets around the Sun and
remember the gravity of the Sun
dominates is the pole that holds the
solar system together and therefore if
you plot the speeds of planets you find
that mercury is whizzing around really
fast around the Sun and Uranus and
Neptune are kind of lulling along on the
outskirts of the solar system partly
because the force of gravity falls off
as one over R square so the Sun the
dominant gravity of the Sun is perceived
by the inner planets and their motions
reflect that this is great so this is
Newton we understand it very well if we
understand the orbits so let's look at
what happens when we measure the speeds
of stars in galaxies so just as we were
looking at the speeds of planets in the
solar system let's look at the stars in
galaxies and so this is just you know
your nice little sombrero galaxy or you
know just a spiral galaxy with a lot of
new young stars and as
function of radius we look at the speeds
of stars and this is what is measured
okay and just to remind you in the solar
system we see that in a galaxy we see
that and so this is I mean this is not
me that theorists making up a little
cartoon this is real data to show you
that most galaxies appear to have these
are called rotation curves and they
appear to flatten out at large radius so
what that's telling you immediately is
that there isn't a dominant source of
gravity sitting in the center that model
is not the model for the mass
distribution of a galaxy so what you
have in galaxies is an extended
distribution of unseen dark matter that
holds the velocities of stars at large
radii up very high very flat and in fact
what is shown here is a compilation of
rotation curves for many nearby galaxies
some in some instances the measurements
actually star from gas that actually
orbits even further outside where you've
run out of stars so it still continues
flat so about you know about this
distance what you're seeing here are gas
particles tracing the gravitational
potential of the galaxy so just to
remind you that you know it's a
completely different model so here's our
conception so this is our current
conception or what a galaxy is so all
the stellar component all the stars that
we see in a galaxy the entire visible
galaxies in that sombrero emission is in
the innermost region what we are really
seeing is the innermost region of the
galaxy however the distribution of mass
the gravitational potential that the
gravity of the stuff that holds a Galaxy
together extends well well out and
that's the dark matter halo which we
don't see optically but it's there
because the motions of the stars
suggests that it's sitting there so
that's sort of the dynamical evidence
for dark matter now let's so now we are
sort of done with Newton let's move on
to what Einstein okay so one of the key
concepts of Einstein's theory of general
relativity rests on the fact that our
universe the entire universe can be
described as a four dimensional manifold
a four dimensional object fabric of
space-time and it's four dimensional
because it has to specify any event in
the universe you need to specify where
it happened the three coordinates XYZ in
space to look like where the event
happen but you also have to tell me when
it happened because light takes a finite
amount of time to reach different parts
of the universe so for example you all
know that light from the Sun takes about
eight minutes to reach us right so if
the site is the Sun shuts off we won't
know for eight minutes and remember the
Sun is our nearest star and by just
extrapolating you can see that the
Starlight that i'm going to show you now
in the shapes of galaxies that we are
going to measure is arriving to us from
galaxies and it has taken billions of
years to get here so we don't actually
know what those galaxies look like today
what we are seeing remember when we look
out we are looking into the past so we
are actually seeing the structures so
all the probes that we have that I'll be
talking to you about we are seeing light
that left these spaces these galaxies
these stars billions of years ago okay
so one of the key concepts as I said
Einstein's inside we're sort of the
connection between mass geometry and
fate right so for example to just
simplify things and to give you a feel
for what the geometry part really is is
that in the presence of any kind of mass
will cause a pot hole in space-time so
you can think of space-time as is fabric
and remember there's nothing above
space-time there's nothing below
space-time the universe is space-time ok
as I said when we see these because you
may think oh maybe you know the universe
there's nothing there I mean this is
that would be the universe that would be
this gridded metric fabric of space-time
and if you have something like the Sun
it causes a little bit of a bump there
and because there's nothing above and
below light from a distance
horse has to travel along the bump has
to hit the pothole before it comes out
to us now if you had a neutron star
which is much more compact is a dense
object then notice it causes a sharper
pot hole in space-time of course these
are my favorite objects black holes
their gravity is so intense that they
actually cause a puncture in space-time
don't ask me where you go to after you
go through the puncher ok that's a talk
for science fiction ok so i just wanted
to motivate now that now that we have an
understanding of the fabric of
space-time light traveled a long space
time and so the deflection of light so
although Newton did not know about space
he knew about gravity he knew that
anything had mass would have an
attractive force of gravity so he asked
her incorrectly Newton and Laplace and
solar and all these people calculated
that if you had light rays because light
at that time was believed to be called
Pascal's not waves but some kind of
particle they thought that it would get
deflected it would get focused
gravitationally around objects that had
mass so they were able to calculate the
deflection of light particles it turns
out that they were sort of on the right
track but they were conceptually off
they were on the right track because
they were just off by a factor of 2 in
the kind of deflections of light that
they predicted so Einstein's theory of
general relativity another reason it's a
beautiful theory is that he came up with
that theory not to explain any
phenomenon this was an ab initio theory
ok and so but he predicted one
prediction of the theory is the
deflection of light the angle by which
light would deflect given a mass that
would cause a certain kind of pot hole
in space-time and so the experiment was
done by the famous British astronomer
arthur eddington during an eclipse and
i'll just show you what actually what he
went and actually measured during an
eclipse so first of all to help you
visualize this is how we conceptualize
light
traveling through the universe these
fuzzy little blobs are dark matter these
gray things are the note that look like
nerve cells I sort of phila mentoring
dark matter and you'll see why I'm sure
you a simulation and you'll see why this
rendering and even think of light is
sort of these tubes sort of from distant
galaxies the light gets bent every time
you see you encounter a Dark Matter blob
and so here's another visualization that
makes it a little clearer what the
measurement was during an eclipse so
during the solar eclipse when Arthur
Eddington made the measurement the earth
and the Sun lined up so you had a pretty
big pothole here in space-time because
the Sun is pretty massive compared to
the earth and so the actual star a star
that was on the other side when the
actual store was actually located there
it appears it appeared to be here
because of the bending of light ok so
the light from That star gets bent and
so you would imagine that it was here
and the reason the way you find this out
eclipse is over lineup has gone pothole
has moved it has been smoothed over much
more efficiently than the potholes on
i-95 so you can see where the where the
original location of the star and this
angle is the deflection angle so this
angle is what Einstein predicted
accurately and this is really what
established gr one of the key
observational pieces that established
the validity of G are definitely on the
scale of the solar system and the data
and the modeling that i'm going to show
you show that Einstein's theory is even
valid on very large cosmic scales this
is of importance because remember we
sort of set Newton aside by saying well
Newton's interesting but it works on
very different scales so what Einstein's
theory is so far shown is that there's a
vast range of scales over which it works
so as you can imagine as physicist and
astrophysicists what we are really
looking for is the breaking point where
does it not work and so a lot of the
work that i will be talking about and a
lot of what motivates me is really
trying to
see where the theory does not match up
the theoretical predictions and the
observational data and of course there
is the middle ground of having to model
it conceptualize the data model it and
test it against the theory that's really
what I do that's the work that I do so I
don't actually procure the data but what
I do is I I look at the theory and I
conceptualize it so that I can connect
it to observations I can extract
information from observations then I can
then use to do precision tests of the
theory and what I'm looking for is to
gaps I'm looking for gaps I'm looking
for places where the theory doesn't work
and when I end I'll explain to you why
that's the most exciting thing to do and
so what we are looking at is light
deflections from distant sources and the
object and room i showed you these
filamentary black dark matter blobs it
turns out that just like galaxies have a
dark matter halo the the the objects in
the universe that have the largest
repositories of dark matter even larger
by proportion compared to a galaxy where
I showed you the extended dark matter
halo is what is called a cluster of
galaxies so it's it's a about a thousand
galaxies that are held together by the
gravitational glue of unseen Dark Matter
vast amounts of unseen dark matter how
do we know that light deflection so
these objects are very very interesting
cosmic lenses so when you have this
light from distant galaxies on its way
to us gets deflected due to the presence
of huge amounts of dark matter that you
cannot see yet but will be revealed to
you very shortly so you can look at the
deflections and what the deflections
actually do is distort the shapes of
galaxies so you end up seeing a
distorted shape of galaxies and from
because we know what the undistorted
shapes of galaxies look like we have a
prior we can figure out all the dark
matter lensing all the light vending all
the potholes that light has been
transmitted through to reach us right so
I remember telling my 10 year old nephew
what I did and so I was you know very
excited that i had this pothole analogy
and i was like oh you know I light comes
in he's like so what you fill potholes
that's what you do that's pretty boring
why do you have to do that in new haven
we have a lot of potholes and deli so
why do you do it here and I was like
okay so here's the sort of the
limitation of analogies but I like that
one so I try not to overuse it okay so
what we have here are clusters that act
as cosmic lenses and you know I couldn't
resist putting one equation you know I
just had to do what because it's so
elegant it's so beautiful so the
deflection angle predicted by gr is
proportional so the amount of deflection
that you get you already know is going
to be proportional to the mass because
it's going to depend on the depth of the
pothole that depends on how massive the
object is and it depends on the path
that the path length of you will that
light has to take and the path length
depends on the geometry depends on all
the Wiggles in space-time so what's very
interesting is if you can find a set of
objects which have a lot of dark matter
will be big deflectors will cause huge
deflections we can measure them then we
can simultaneously measure the mass of
dark matter in those objects turns out
it's mostly dark matter and you get a
handle on the geometry so and of course
it is about alignment things have to
line up to be deflected to give us sort
of observable measurable deflections
with the instruments that we currently
have so it turns out that deflection is
proportional to the mass and the
strength depends on the geometry of the
universe so you can see why i love
clusters so clusters in one go are
giving us a handle on both the dark
matter and dark energy right so these
are the perfect cosmological
Astrophysical laboratories because they
allow you so you have you can get
constraints on dark energy which is
encapsulated in the geometry and on dark
matter because the bulk of the matter
that's doing the bending even though we
see the galaxies is the unseen stuff is
actually dark matter so this is a very
nice
visualization again to show you that you
have a cluster of galaxies and you can
see the bump in space-time that they've
created because they have a large large
amount of dark matter associated with
them and you see a light rays bent ok so
is this scene in the universe it turns
out that gravitational lensing by
clusters is seen ubiquitously so
clusters are rare objects but as and
when we see clusters we see a huge
amount of lensing but of course we need
the resolution of the Hubble Space
Telescope thankfully I arrived on the
scene well after not only Hubble was
launched but it's optics were corrected
so you know I wouldn't have been in this
field and this field would not have
happened if Hubble had not been there
and its optics hadn't been corrected so
you by I you can pick out all the
gravitationally lensed auric so these
are background galaxies that are sitting
behind the cluster that have gotten
extremely distorted in shape and
sometimes they can get so destroyed it
distorted that remember we saw the light
rays as tubes that they can actually
split into two so you can end up seeing
two images where in reality there's only
one object so the light can get so
severely bent that it can be stretched
out and get split into multiples so you
can see multiple copies of the same
object and we do yeah
the key that week it doesn't know a way
but yeah no but you could I did you
catch me saying classes are actually
very rare so they're covering fraction
on the sky is very low so most of the
patches of sky that we look at they are
not as distorted they're very weakly
distorted so we have an idea of the
prior undistorted shapes of galaxies by
looking at many many different places
that's a great question though so here
all of these highly distorted arcs that
you see are telling us there's a huge
amount of matter here there's light here
obviously but there's a huge amount of
dark matter here because look at the
light bending here look at the shape of
these arcs okay so let me just tell you
why clusters of galaxies which I think
are the best cosmic laboratories
extraordinary cosmic laboratories
because they give you a handle into both
dark energy and dark matter this is what
we know about them they're about one
percent of the mass isn't galaxies stars
and galaxies that we just saw so for
example this is a cluster seen by Hubble
all of these yellow fuzzy things are
galaxies that are in the cluster the
things are in the background or either
these reddish or bluish objects those
are the lengths things that are behind
the cluster and so only one percent of
the mass is in galaxies ten percent is
in hot gas which you don't see because
that emits in the x-ray and we are
looking at an optical image and the rest
as I'll show you reconstructing the Dark
Matter map is all dark matter so the big
open questions right are how much mass
is there in clusters how much dark
matter is really sitting in clusters as
opposed to individual galaxies and that
we know because they also have dark
matter haloes so in terms of the
composition of the universe how is this
dark matter smeared how is it partition
then there's a big question that light
and mass seem to kind of trace each
other so when I see galaxies I see a
dark matter halo associated with the
galaxy the question is are there Dark
Matter blobs floating around with no
galaxies we don't know yet okay so we're
looking for that because it depends on
the efficiency of four
nation of stars so there could be
locations Dark Matter clumps that never
have the right conditions to assemble
stores the theory predicts there should
be a lot of them so then we want to know
how in detail how the dark matter is
distributed and this granularity of dark
matter this is the question that I have
been interested from the beginning of
starting my work on gravitational
lensing because as I said unraveling the
nature of dark matter has been very very
difficult but I will just show you that
the granularity holds some interesting
insights into its very nature okay and
another thing in lensing that's
important like real estate is location
so its surrender fittest alignment right
you need it you need you need to be at
the right place and if you are you could
get lens and you could get dramatically
lens so if you line up that little gray
blob is the dark matter distribution
that could be around a cluster smooth
dark matter distribution round the
cluster so if things really line up you
could have that a normal-looking galaxy
stretched out into a big circle like a
ring and that's called an Einstein ring
or if this mass distribution notice this
is geometrically different this is like
an ellipsoid that's sphere you can have
a different configuration if things line
up you can get an image that is
quadrupling image that looks like this
that's an Einstein cross but in reality
a cluster looks more like this Plus this
ok so when you have a lot of clumpy dark
matter you get the kind of kind of
observational data that I just showed
you from the Hubble image so this is an
animation nothing in the universe is
moving but it's just to show you the
range of stretched out shapes that you
can actually see so this is a background
screen where you have blue circles
everything is a circle so I've assumed
that all galaxies form as little circles
on the sky and then I plop a huge
cluster with a lot of dark matter and
the amount of dark matter is shown in
the shading in the pink so you have a
lot of dark mites very dense in the
center but you have a lot of its
stretching out you can see it's sort of
slowly fading so where you have a lot of
dark matter you have an extreme amount
of stretching like deflection
and as you go further out it gets softer
but you can see that there's an
alignment things are sort of swirling
around where you have this part of dark
matter so what we are really trying to
do and so me and my collaborators have
been trying to do for several years now
is to try and infer looking at the image
looking at the blue things which would
be the Hubble Space Telescope image
trying to infer what this pink stuff is
what reconstruct the mass that's
actually causing the deflection so we
know quite a lot about it as i said the
theory is very well understood its
elegant it's simple and basically as i
said it depends on location what we are
seeing here is if you have a circular
galaxy distant galaxies shown as red
blue yellow and green depending on the
location with respect to line up that we
just saw in the previous slide depending
on that line up if you line up just
right like the red one you can have four
copies for images of the same object and
how do we know it's the same object
signature spectral signature you go out
and take the spectrum of those four
blobs that identical romance a
fingerprint and the probability that any
for things that lie just like that has
practically zero in the universe so as a
function of location we now know all the
configurations that we can look for in
the data and we can use that to map what
the dark matter what the matter is and
it's principally dark so the other thing
i want to show you in that little
graphic here are these galaxies room but
that's a conception of a galaxy that i
showed you a little bit of starlight and
a huge dark matter halo so galaxies so
this these are galaxies that are in the
foreground the blue blobs are distant
galaxies notice that even if you don't
have extreme stretching you have a
coherent stretch out effect you have a
distortion you have a tangential
stretching and so we look for these
signals in the data and this is what
Hubble did this is the same patch of sky
the same cluster notice that you saw
this art this is from the Canada France
voy a telescope and look at the
resolution you can actually resolve
star-forming not
in this galaxy that's been stretched out
so Hubble has really transformed this
field and you can pick out it allows you
to pick out all these multiple images
because some of them are faint but it
turns out it in general you can think of
gravitational lensing and sort of a
mapping a mathematical mapping between
the source plane distant galaxies and
the image plane what we see and it turns
out one of the properties of this
mapping is the surface brightness is
preserved so when you stretch things out
you actually magnify them so you are not
only a cosmic lens you're a cosmic
telescope so clusters bring into view
galaxies that you would never otherwise
see no matter how big a telescope you
build so they're just incredible
incredible beasts okay so for example i
want to show you these are not just
single so there's another one where you
see something image four times and it's
this sort of spoke bicycle wheel shaped
galaxy and so let's come back to this
cluster so I first show you my sort of
reconstructions and the Dark Matter map
for this cluster but before I do that I
would like to give you a view of what
our theoretical understanding is at the
moment let's see if the movie is
starting so what this movie is we have
to start and stop it you go back I can't
tell if it's starting okay
oh sorry
you're getting an early preview of it
should work now okay so what you see
here is a simulation of dark matter
assembly in the universe so dark matter
assembles just by gravity rumor there no
other forces this is just gravitational
aggregation just mocked up to look like
light yellow this is not light this is
dark matter so you see that this is a
region of the universe that's going to
end up like that cluster that we saw
2218 and what you see is a lot of little
blobs very granular colliding so it
turns out that dark matter is actually
collisionless it doesn't actually
collide these sort of two particles kind
of gray's each other they don't actually
go head-on like gas order they don't
actually collide that's that's another
peculiar nature of what whatever this
Dark Matter might be made of so this is
how a dark matter halo that is going to
host a cluster of galaxies assembles in
the universe so what you see here are
lots of blobs is it's a very very
granular distribution of dark matter so
that's what the theory predicts okay so
this is a theoretical prediction and it
depends very much on the nature of dark
matter the amount of granularity that
survives at later times depends on the
nature of the particle so notice this is
a warm dark matter particle which is lot
less granular very smooth distribution
this is called dark matter this is the
particle that we believe our universe is
composed of very very granular but you
can discriminate between these two if
you are able to count the blobs but if
you can somehow quantify the granularity
from data if you can map dark matter
from lensing if I can tell you where all
the little galaxy halos are in the
cluster then I can count them up and I
can compare with the simulation that I
just showed you so that's the task that
I have been interested in and that's
what I got started doing way back when
so you model the gravitational effect of
the cluster of the entire cluster of
galaxies which is mostly dark matter and
the sum of a component that's kind of a
smooth smoothly distributed component
and then a whole
bunch of blobs and lots of blobs so when
you use the data the Hubble data so this
is my mass reconstruction so these are
the gravitational equipotential for this
cluster so this bright galaxies is this
guy what you see as a yellow bunny
rabbit is the region within which behind
which any galaxy that lies behind that
region will get multiplied imaged will
have five or four as you have an odd
number of images always so it turns out
that we can then partition from the
light bending that we see we can
partition how much of the Dark Matter
should be smooth and how much should be
sitting in lumps and when you do that
partitioning with the data this is the
rendition of the Dark Matter clumps so
you have the smooth component you see
this sort of mound and then on top of it
you see these spikes which are the
clumps of dark matter so the goal here
is to then so this we've extracted the
granularity of dark matter from the data
just with Einstein's predictions of
light funding now we go to the
simulation where we've put in some
initial conditions for the universe that
we've gleaned from other observations
nothing to do with lensing we let the
movie go and we then look at the age at
the same time in the universe where we
have an image of this cluster right when
it formed and it has assembled and we
compare the granularity so this is just
to assure you so this is the kind of
work that I do trying to use theoretical
concepts and ideas so that you can
translate observational data to confront
a theoretical model okay and so this is
just to show you a nicer rendition of
that zoom in so ya know this is a static
picture so we compare the static picture
in the simulation at the red shift at
the cosmic time where this object has
formed and the image that we take which
is a one time snapshot they
the evolution is understood by going
back to the simulation and looking at
clusters that are in different stages
not the same guy but different objects
that are in various stages of growth and
evolution so this is a cluster again
this is the one that had the five
bicycle spoke wheels and that's a lot of
constraints so we can actually do a
really nice job and so this is the Dark
Matter map so we have Hubble data out
too much further than the previous case
so notice I can tell you about all the
clumps out to a much larger scale so
this is to give you an idea of scale
this is the region that is shown in
yellow so these are sort of dark matter
and so it is from these kinds of maps
that we have inferred that more than
ninety percent of the total mass of a
cluster is sitting in these clumps and
we can now say what fraction of the mass
is sitting in clumps of different sizes
and that's a characteristic that I can
derive from the data and that's a
prediction from the theory and I can
confront the theory to the data so this
is what we could do earlier so this is
from some earlier published work of mine
so these this is the clump the
distribution of clumps and this is the
simulation the black histogram with the
gray area is comparison with clusters
with simulated clusters that form in our
little box universe and the dispersion
tells you this is from combining the
data of many many clusters and so this
coming back to Shankar's question these
are actually chaps these are five chaps
at different stages of evolution and
we've compared them to a simulated
sample at those same stages of evolution
notice this guy sort of an outlier it's
a pretty bad egg the reason this one is
so bad is that it's actually not one
object but it's actually two clusters
that are merging and they're merging
exactly like this because we are more
likely to find these guys because they
will lens more dramatically right
they're lined up they're going to their
surface mass density is very high so
they're going to bend light much more
dramatically so we are likely to pick
them up but it turns out in the
simulation volume remember we can
simulate only a small volume of the
universe there isn't a B
that looks like that so okay so let me
quickly skip on so they're very detailed
studies one can do so this is a
reconstruction of that cluster that I
just showed you and blue is the
distribution of dark matter so that's
what you don't see okay so there's a lot
of math sitting there and that's just
the light this is the light and mass and
notice they don't race each other quite
well and so this is an open question as
I said right so as I said I've been sort
of waxing lyrical about how clusters are
these amazing objects cosmic
laboratories because we can actually get
a dark energy using them so we can
calibrate the lens which is like you
know going to an optometrist and getting
your lens your spectacles calibrated we
can calibrate a lens so that we can then
measure the dependence on the distances
for objects that are lensed doing that
so you know for those of you who sort of
know what is going on in dark energy
remember I said we parameterize it with
some w some little parameter so these
are kinds of kind of bananas that people
from who do say supernova to look for
dark energy this was sort of the
discovery of dark energy came out of a
banana like this so this method also
gives you constraints in this plane that
are obviously not competitive at the
moment they weren't at this time but
what has changed so what has changed my
life has changed it's become incredibly
busy crazy because of this new project
that I was involved very much in sort of
its Genesis which is getting the Hubble
Space Telescope before it dies it may
die any time in the next two to three
years to look very very deeply because
remember for lending data what we want
is very very deep data so that we can
pick out all the itsy bitsy pieces that
are multiple images and figure them out
so the Hubble Space Telescope I was part
of a science working group that
suggested you know what is the most
brave optimistic risky observation that
you could do you could stare at six
pieces of sky for the equivalent of a
couple of months and so that's what's
happened so that's what's happening what
does that allow you to do that allows
you to make a Dark Matter map that is
has much more fidelity
higher resolution and this is one of
those regions another cluster this is a
cluster that was observed as part of the
Hubble frontier fields so notice this
guy is kind of an elongated very
dramatic one and here is the dark matter
distribution so this is clearly one of
those cases where two things have
smashed into each other right so they're
very complicated but we can resolve them
okay then the question is has the theory
moved along so you've got higher
resolution data do you have good enough
simulation so it turns out that they
needed to be updated seriously and the
methods the methods that I developed
over the years have all needed an
upgrade because they are just not they
were pretty good with sparse data but
with this kind of dense sampling of data
the methods daily need serious
improvement so what have we done what's
improved so all those histograms I
showed you earlier we're sitting here so
we could find clumps over a range of two
orders of magnitude with this new data
we can push and we can find many more
smaller clumps and as you saw we want to
push this because this gives us a hint
on the nature of dark matter a lot of
little blobs is what we saw so we are
putting it we are sort of trying to push
and we've pushed and what we see now
what you see the swath are the new
simulations the updated state-of-the-art
simulations of cluster formation and
guess what the theory looks really done
good and as I said you know I always
thought I could become famous by showing
that the theory doesn't work right
didn't happen the theory seems to work
very very well and I'm often asked these
questions by people who read the press
carefully and they say well you know
there's this direct Dark Matter doesn't
seem to be found and they haven't
detected it and also the recent
underground experiments people have said
nope we don't see it so why should why
should I really study what what am i
after right if we can't find out what
this particle is well so before I come
to my last slide I want to show you this
hot off the press image that the reason
why i'm slightly Draghi's because it's
woken up this morning by BBC News to
comment on this this is a new Dark
Matter map that was produced by the dark
energy collaboration just want to point
out this is a huge part of the sky
and this is a resolution right so my
iphone 6 is I think about 20 megapixels
this is 517 megapixels enormously
resolved right and a huge batch of the
sky so the full moon is like half a
degree across this is two degrees or so
this huge amount region of sky these
dark blobs each of these dark blobs is a
cluster I just showed you the zoom in
and I was looking at the granularity in
there so what is very intriguing about
this map is that light and mass still
seem to trace each other quite well even
on these scales and this has been
obtained from gravitational lensing and
now because of the scale right we don't
have huge distortions we don't have all
these HD bitsy pieces we have those
slight tweaks that I showed you those
little slight stretches changes in shape
very systematic statistical enormous
amount of hard work to get to this map
because the distortions are 1% in shape
statistically so you really have to have
a lot of objects to paint that down okay
so while I look for deviations people
always ask me okay so doc matters not
found every year someone tells you we
still haven't found it we still haven't
found it and you're still doing this and
you are saying oh I'm pushing it and
pushing it so what are you pushing and
why so I just want to stop with this
historical anecdote that you know when
there were deviations in the orbit of
Uranus from Newton's prediction right in
the 1800s Owain lovey a who was this
French astronomer he predicted that that
wobble was due to the presence of a
planet again he calculated the orbit of
the planet he predicted Neptune and then
Neptune was found right and it turns out
that the deviation in the orbit of
Uranus from Newton's prediction
basically he predicted it and he said
there should be another planet it was
found now there's deviations in the
orbit of mercury okay there were
deviations those procession in the orbit
of mercury and urban lava he said oh
there should be another planet between
the Sun and Mercury he called it valken
and there were people said in order
they didn't find it it does not exist
what that needed that that small
deviation from Newton's predictions
around Mercury's orbit the precession of
the orbit it actually needed Einstein so
the whole theory needed to be upended
because of that you know the same
explanation did not work in the two
instances where you saw the deviations
in the orbit in the case of mercury now
that you all know gr mercury is very
close to the Sun so it's really sampling
very close to the pothole the bottom of
the bottle right so gr becomes important
and so what we are looking for we're
looking for something that doesn't fit
because that what doesn't fit could
either be a signature of the theory
needing refinement so the existing
theory this lambda CDM cold dark matter
model might just work if it needs a
little bit of a tweak or refinement or
the disagreement may point to the
requirement for something fundamentally
new so that's the hope so many people
like me are sort of trying to figure out
what the gaps are and understanding what
the gaps in translate to in terms of
potential new physics so I'll stop here
thank you so much for your attention
right manner exists at various densities
sorry duck like yeah great question it
could look the question is just as
normal matter ordinary atoms exist in
various states and various and various
densities can Dark Matter exists and
various states and very sensitive oh
absolutely but Occam's razor to start
out with we think it's one kind of
particle and that's what we're looking
for but you know they're there earlier
before we converged on this cold dark
matter as the particle people thought
that you know the dead neutron stars
black holes these compact objects the
remnants of compact objects could
constitute dark matter turns out they
may contribute to the budget they may be
but they are not the principal part of
the budget so yeah for simplicity at the
moment they've been recent suggestions
that perhaps we should consider two
different kinds of dark matter sandy the
spy diagrams yeah those are galaxies
those are galaxies so that's a great
question for this yeah so these blue
regions are void as well so you see a
lot of under densities regions where you
don't even have dark matter even dark
matter is smeared very lightly what you
saw in those PI diagrams of the CFA
redshift survey in the 80s was actually
a galaxy survey so they were just seeing
the light and they were looking at the
clustering of the light to understand
what it might say about the clustering
of mass that was unseen so now we've
made a quantum leap so we can actually
not only see the light simultaneously we
can reconstruct because this background
screen from lensing the voids in the
matter distribution and what we see is
that the over densities are orange and
red and you see that wherever you see
dark matter over densities there's
associated light over densities but
intriguingly some of these void regions
the blue regions where there is very
little dark matter you are seeing an
occasional galaxy cluster or so so this
is you know this is just from I think
five percent of their data so it remains
to be seen how what kind of view we get
as time goes on right here no other
question is our measurements of the
anisotropy in this Cosmic Microwave
Background you know that map that I
showed you in the first couple of slides
where it carries the imprint of
everything that is encountered the
photons carry that imprint so there
you're looking at temperature
fluctuations of one part in 10 to the
minus 5 so what you're looking here at
aroma tony is 1 part in 101 percent
change in shape roughly that kind of
fidelity of what we are mapping so
they're not quite there but they're in
agreement this is what is interesting
intriguing because from that from the
Cosmic Microwave Background we can
predict the number of clumpy things that
these photons have encountered and we
can create a power spectrum as you know
Joe we can make the power spectrum and
that power spectrum is the power
spectrum that matches what we see even
on very very large skills like in this
new map that was released so there is
concordance sadly there's still
concordance
matter density we're looking at the
surface mass density you're actually
looking at the projected 2d surface mass
density we're not looking we are not
mapping the stress-energy tensor you
actually write that we have to make
another sort of leap on the nature of
this beast which is why we think it's a
cold dark matter to sort of the sluggish
set of particles that don't travel very
fast and we create it's like an ideal
fluid it's actually a peculiar ideal
fluid it's a pressure less fluid that's
what this cold dark matter is yeah cliff
you have another question well I think
the next generation we need to open the
window in other wavelengths so for
example the mid-infrared far infrared
and the infrared parts of the spectrum
we've only started developing the
detectors that are sensitive in the
infrared so we need to open these new
windows into the universe and so the
jwst to james webb space telescope hey i
want all you know i want all the
telescopes to be on all the time I want
lots of grant money for theory and big
computers i want it all right but the
astronomy community has kind of made the
decision that they need to you know have
a set of facilities that are phased in
and phased out so the money can go the
limited budget sadly can be channeled
appropriately are they they're not the
same thing they both have gravitational
when I thought I was hearing all that
dark matter and the lens and get was
no no no no but does this is still dark
matter that the survey eventually hopes
to get a handle at dark energy just a
taste yeah no no that's the name of the
survey of the group of collaboration
that's produced its data if you want to
go and look more today you should go
look at that survey yeah no no that's
yeah what they were after dark energy
but dark matter came for free for what
they want to do but I'm more interested
in the dark matter and it's a dark
matter this is about dark matter their
survey has more ambitious goals on doing
remember that rulers that I was telling
you yeah okay one moment please lot of
uncertainty about that so the question
is what do we know about dark matter
locally right so that we think that it's
very sparsely distributed around the
solar system there's not a whole lot and
how much is how it tapers and how it
falls off in the vicinity of the solar
system is debated and we think that one
of the reasons that you don't see any
detection Zyzz because we have it
completely off on what the flux should
be locally but we think it has to be
quite low because we have the
sensitivities of many many instruments
now that have put limits on what it
should be nearby can follow up that day
yeah more about it more about especially
I don't know exactly it's so the
question is how how r could dark matter
and dark energy be related in some way
so they're actually the opposite of each
other right so dark matter actually
coagulates gravity attractive dark
energy somehow pushes everything apart
because it's powering the accelerating
expansion of the universe so while Dark
Matter will tend to bring things
together dark energy pulls them apart
and this is reflected as if we don't
know what it is the only thing we know
is that we have measured what we think
this contribution to the overall cosmic
inventory is from dark energy and that
is seventy percent so the dark energy
the way I told you those bananas that
are used to figure out what it is it is
consistent in physics with the vacuum
energy of the universe however the
theoretical expectation for that number
is off by a hundred and twenty orders of
magnitude from what is measured so I
mean it would be fair to say the problem
is not solved I mean really don't we
don't know what it is at all okay one
more question and then we'll retire to
the reception so right here
no probably one of the very very blue
areas here I would think yeah would have
the kind of dance it's not here because
these are not these are maps yeah so
something like that actually quite quite
blue quite devoid that's what the direct
deter the detection experimental limits
are suggesting that the dark matter
density is so low it's below the
sensitivity of all the instruments at
this point which is why we haven't
detected it so I think it would be fair
to say i don't know the calibration of
this but I mean something like that that
you know be very very low okay well
thank you so much for expanding our
horizons dramatically today so I request